[Music]
i'm definitely gonna i'm gonna go on a
binge man you inspired me man you should
man i haven't like been very good about
watching anything lately and my
inspiration has just been in the [ __ ]
and then it kind of clicked with me the
other day when you brought up that
french movie i was like why am i not
like watching things i used to do that
way more you know just
cruise for like some shitty two dollar
movie on itunes and go like what's up
with this there's a lot of movies that
even through poor execution there's a
lot of fun ideas there that can inspire
you which is really interesting i also
watch a lot of catfish lately oh the the
show yeah it's really bad yeah you like
catfish
that was [ __ ]
of course the show yeah oh the show you
weren't just looking at a pond yeah well
no i'm at the uh well there's a movie
the series is actually based around the
movie yeah you see neve
uh
he uh he got catfished so that's that's
his inspiration to help others not get
catfished right so yeah yeah
i thought you just head down to you know
japanese restaurant and just take a look
at the pond i mean i would love that too
catfish are a beautiful creature nah um
what season are you on i start well i
went on hulu
and i was like oh my god i forgot about
this and i was i looked i think it's
season like six
five or six
and it had
like 48 episodes whoa and i was like
huh
like what what what is the
what is the like filming like and then
what was the release schedule when it
came out that had to be weekly just like
i mean that or like is it a multiple
year season or something that's weird
like no it's very odd i think i think
they're because like the quality of the
cinematography is dog [ __ ] so i think
it's just all right dude
i mean those are working people there's
a union workers right there hey and
they're they're working they're
definitely working they're working and
the thing too with those reality shows
is yeah they're terrible but it all
comes through in the editing oh yeah
yeah i mean yeah but like neve but the
the biggest i just have a couple gripes
about it with me i'm not gonna no i mean
i don't know him personally you're just
like i'll go grayson i know i have a
couple gripes with catfish his hair his
haircut sucks well
i think he's actually kind of handsome
no all right
okay now how many how many times do i
have to tell say that i think men are
handsome on this podcast for me for it
to just be let alone doesn't matter a
couple times well you're kind of
handsome on the camera
yeah there you go again you know what
yeah you are handsome thanks everybody
that is in this place is handsome
all right
there's a woman here
that's why i said everybody okay i don't
want to say
all the guys and the one woman here are
handsome that felt wrong yeah but i was
also waiting for more of a reaction
behind the curtain i was like
thank you
thanks no it's just all of them in
unison
thank you hunter exactly thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you i was
expecting a chance but in catfish they
have a a person named max yeah who is
his buddy or whatever but he just holds
a camera the whole time yep and it's so
pointless
that all the foot they rarely use the
footage because
it's like it's like a like a 200 walmart
camcorder yeah he's holding he's just
like okay now this is crazy yeah you
know what i mean yeah that [ __ ] just
bothers me no he shouldn't be there okay
or that it's just like he's
yeah
yeah
looking at the laptop as if we're gonna
use that foot why would we not just take
the screen recording yeah and we would
you thank god let's look at that
compressed uh
video
that you shot in 720p there he is look
at him even in the even the problem this
shot they have this little tiny camera
it's so tiny dude it's so tiny yeah it's
look how big his hands are compared to
that camera it's literally a
point-and-shoot from that is 2001. that
is a comic he bought that at a spy store
yeah
you know where they get like those
little hoes
he's like hey do you have something that
just makes me look like a giant and the
guy's like this will feel so small that
you'll have you don't have a pen with a
camera in it do you yeah exactly
it's just holding that [ __ ] up
or not i know he's got it in like a yeah
like that and he like leans over a
little yeah
[ __ ] what do you call it pocket
protector little titty pocket yeah you
just
say that a little louder mm-hmm
could you could you say that like yeah
it's just like super blown out audio
that they use sometimes
[Laughter]
he doesn't live in arizona at all
yeah
but the show is great also his neve
smile look how proud he is he is
i drew them
bring that up on my instagram go ahead
and put i was so fascinated with uh
neves like heath ledger joker smiling he
has it i was like grin man i was like
this dude is handsome he's got a
beautiful smile he's with this silver
fox i gotta draw these guys there's jay
schlot with balls for sideburns yes
and look at that
yeah it looks just like him yeah
his little tiny camera point at your
face
i use a little jpeg of a
front porch of the background
that's good
i love it
yeah so what so what's your gripe
besides max or is that just just the
show is just like it's it's it's catered
around
it feels so
mean spirited a lot of the time yeah of
like some of these cases are so obvious
yeah and it's like people are in like
really poor living conditions or like
you can just tell that like
i don't know it's just
kind of a freak show situation a bit
yeah to where it's like when i watch it
i'm like
and then you're like and the people
sometimes are like he's like okay well
you got to know that you're probably
getting catfished yeah they say that
yeah yeah they do one of those
you know like that and it's like a
[ __ ] like
it's like a
photo of like who's the guy who played
thor
yeah chris hemsworth it's like a photo
of chris hemsworth or whatever and like
a girl would be like you know i think
he's beautiful and he says that he loves
me and stuff he's like do you think he
could pull like that yeah that's chris
that's hemsworth yeah right yeah they're
just being sassy and shitty yeah like
really kind of condescending in a way
where it's like it makes i just feel bad
the whole time
well this is who it is they just turned
their phone around and neve and max are
like oh
literally like there's been times like
let's look it up on facebook and he's
like
okay we got a match and they're just
doing things that you could they're just
dropping images into google
and being like okay so this is where
this is this if it's like ghost hunters
where it's like the technology's made up
you know this is literally dragging a
jpeg
into google it'd be like okay this is
where it came from
oh okay
okay
apparently he's a movie star okay well
that's kind of weird he said he was from
dayton ohio
that's kind of odd right
it's like yeah dude and i had to call
her like hey uh rebecca yeah
uh
i don't i think he might be catfish he's
like okay
that's just it's like sad like you want
to fly out there uh okay they're like
dude i feel like they're looking for the
worst stories like someone is like i
used the library's computer and i met
this man on a website
and uh he is very attractive but i have
concerns and yeah it's just a craigslist
posting and it's [ __ ] chris hemsworth
and every time too it's just they always
explain so like what so you've never
seen them know every time that we voice
chat
uh
he's shrouded in darkness
there's
his camera doesn't work or something and
then always max need to do this to each
other
yeah yeah yeah we got him yeah
yeah i mean um
sorry just say that one more time yeah
exactly so you're dumb
is what it's like what they're really
saying it's just it's so uh
disheartening
it's it's brutal and then but i love the
times though and they probably do this
uh i guess because it's all probably
pre-planned and stuff and actually doing
research on the show usually the people
that are catfishing
catfishing catfishing the person reach
out to the show so it's usually never
the people that are like hey damn so
it's like